The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Today, teaching equations and
how to teach equations in a
way that promotes long lasting
learning and understanding.
OK.
So the first example--
I'm going to give you
two choices for
starting the example.
So this is example one for
teaching equations.
This is Hardy-Weinberg
equilibrium.
So here's one way
you could start.
So if a locust has n alleles
and the organism is
polyploid--
so that means it has, let's say,
C copies of chromosomes.
OK.
So there's n alleles.
So the allele frequencies
are P1 through Pn.
Then we're going to deduce
the genotype frequencies.
So this is the multinomial
middle coefficient C. Choose
K1, K2, K3, all the way to Kn.
And K1 through Kn are the
number of copies of each
allele with K1 plus blah, blah,
blah, to Kn, all equal
to C.
So you could actually state
that and then prove it.
That's option A. So now I'll
give you option B for starting
the same topic.
So option B is from Hardy.
So in Hardy's Mathematician's
Apology, he writes, I have
never done anything useful.
No discovery of mine has made or
is likely to make, directly
or indirectly, for good or ill,
the least difference to
the amenity of the world.
That's a very interesting,
very bold statement.
And amazingly, for
such a brilliant
mathematician, it's wrong.
And today, what we're going to
do is we're going to look at
an example of the discovery
by Hardy--
the Hardy-Weinberg
equilibrium--
that does make a difference to
the amenity of the world and
helps you actually understand
genetics.
OK.
So the option B is to quote
Hardy and then point out the
contradiction between what
he said and what
we're going to do.
Now, also, in option B, you
can go a bit farther.
You can say, well, why
would Hardy have said
something like that?
And indeed, why would he have
said something like that in
his Apology?
Well, it's actually probably
hard to appreciate on this
side of the Atlantic, because
since the Civil War, we've
never had a war that just
basically devastated entire
countries on our own soil.
Whereas in Europe, the memories
of World War I are
very strong.
So if anyone's from Europe,
you know that.
In every English chapel, there's
names on the wall of
all the people who died in
the, quote, Great War.
So World War I had
a very strong
effect on European society.
And one of the effects was on
European science and people's
attitude towards science.
So poison gas was invented
partly by German chemists.
Hopper was one of them.
And in the end, he committed
suicide, partly maybe because
of what he had done.
No, sorry.
His wife committed suicide.
I forget if--
I should check that.
But basically, people in the
family were so unhappy about
what had happened just there
that there was a suicide.
And furthermore, science after
that was considered--
World War I was considered
the chemists' war.
So there was a wish to distance
oneself from those
kinds of horrible effects.
And the quote from Hardy is
actually a reflection of that.
He himself was very
strongly anti-war.
He left Cambridge because
Cambridge fired Bertrand
Russell for protesting World War
I. So Hardy left Cambridge
for a professorship in Oxford
and only came back basically
12 or 13 years later
to Cambridge.
So that statement of his partly
a wish that he's hoping
nothing he's done has any effect
on the world because in
his mind, maybe most
effects are bad.
Well, but actually, he
did have an effect.
The effect is Hardy-Weinberg.
Even if you discount everything
you did in number
theory, there's Hardy-Weinberg,
and it has an
effect and we're going
to look at it.
So let me ask you rhetorical
question.
If you're a student, which would
you find more engaging,
more inviting?
This one or this one?
Who votes for that one?
OK.
Yeah.
Now, why?
So now think of-- so the
question I'm going to ask you
to think about just for a minute
with one or two of your
neighbors is why.
So yeah, this is definitely
more engaging.
In terms of the principles we
talked about last time, what
makes this way of introducing it
more engaging, more likely
to bring students in, more
likely to make them want to
learn about Hardy-Weinberg.
OK.
So find a neighbor or two we
think about the principles
behind
option B. OK.
So I'll rudely interrupt you.
And good thing I did the voice
exercise so I can project all
the way into the back.
So what reasons for option B or
against option A, which is
the same thing?
Yes.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Brian.
PROFESSOR: Brian.
I'm going to try to learn
people's names.
So go ahead.
AUDIENCE: The reason
against option A--
when you start out that way, you
are activating the ability
that students have to transfer
material from the blackboard
to their notes and then pass
it to their brains.
PROFESSOR: Right--
through the wave.
Yeah.
I'm activating the ability
of the students to
basically take dictation.
Or as someone said, teaching
is an excellent way to
transfer material from the notes
of the teacher to the
notes of the student without
it passing through
the minds of either.
So I'll call that not A. So
that's the not symbol.
Not A is--
so I'm basically asking to do
dedication which doesn't
necessarily lead to any
kind of learning.
They could, for example, copy
all of that down but not
really understand of it.
OK.
Other--
yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Susannah.
PROFESSOR: Susannah.
AUDIENCE: This is right brain?
So it's easier to remember
and ingest it.
And maybe even identify
the theorems.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Right.
And so B is the story.
I'll give you an example of
how stories can be so
powerful, and just
even the word.
So a big commercial
publisher--
this was several years ago--
they wanted me to write a
freshman physics textbook.
I had actually just put up a
proposal on the web saying, we
should write a freshman physics
textbook that is based
on the history of science.
And they saw it and they
thought, oh, that's great.
So they flew me from England to
California to talk to them.
And they liked it mostly.
But they said, history--
so there was the word.
They liked the idea as I talked
about it, but the word
history really frightened
them.
And then, I'm still amazed--
I had this amazing insight
of just two letters.
I thought, oh, wait.
I can actually explain
to them what I mean.
I said, well, actually, if you
just take away that part, what
I'm really talking
about is that.
And it was interesting.
As soon as they saw the word
story and they saw that
history doesn't have to be
names, dates, facts--
I think that's what they
were seeing it as--
they saw it as story, which
is actually its origin
in French or Latin--
[FRENCH].
They all of a sudden were
totally convinced.
They said, oh, yeah.
That's exactly how we should
do the textbook.
For various reasons, basically
because I wanted to be a
freely licensed book, we didn't
actually sign a contract.
But it's an example of how
powerful story is and how
people who actually spend their
lives thinking about
teaching and reaching students--
in other words,
this educational publisher knew
the importance of story.
But if you present it as just
dry history, it's not so
interesting.
So story--
yeah.
So let's see.
Who haven't I heard from?
I haven't heard from Adrian.
Yeah, and then you're next.
AUDIENCE: So the fact that it's
a contradiction creates
some sort of tension from
linear thought.
And it's more of
a exploratory.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So there's a contradiction.
And the contradiction creates
some kind of tension.
So the tension creates
interest.
So every good story needs
some kind of tension.
So the tension here, the
contradiction, is that Hardy
wanted to do nothing that could
harm people, basically.
And so he was like, OK, well,
anything could be used, even
if it's for good, for ill.
So let me just back off from
all of that and say I'm not
going to do anything that has
an effect, an application.
I'm a pure mathematician.
His most famous book is A Course
of Pure Mathematics.
Well, maybe his most famous
book is that book that I
quoted from, A Mathematician's
Apology.
His most famous math book is
probably A Course of Pure
Mathematics.
And that's what he wanted
to be known for.
And that's in contradiction
with the fact and no, even
Hardy couldn't help
an application--
an actually very,
very common one.
It's taught in every
single introductory
biology course, probably.
OK.
So you need tension.
Now, that's a general principle
of learning there--
the idea of story and
tension and paradox.
So the one way that, as a
undergraduate in physics, I
learned a ton of physics, me
and my friends were doing
problem sets together.
And a lot of problems were just
grinding through math.
So we didn't learn a hell
of a lot from that.
But we were in the library late
at night, the physics
library, ordering pizza, and
trying to do a problem set,
and we just got to making
up physics paradoxes--
perpetual motion machines.
We'd invent perpetual motion
machines and try to get the
other person to figure out
what was wrong with it.
Sometimes, we didn't even know
what was wrong with it and
we'd both try to
figure it out.
So from that kind of tension--
tension is almost, in a way,
self teaching, because as long
as the tension's there,
you know you're not at
the end of the story.
You know there's more to do.
So the same thing-- as long as
there was perpetual motion
going on and we hadn't found the
reason, we knew we weren't
done with the problem.
We didn't have to ask a teacher
to say, well, is this
right, because it was basically
self teaching.
As long as the tension
was there, we knew
that we weren't finished.
So yeah--
another general principle,
stories and tension.
Let's see.
There was a comment over--
yes.
Tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Wing Ho.
PROFESSOR: Wing Ho?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So this along the line that
the teacher should make
themselves more human, because
Hardy-Weinberg sounds like
such a big name you
would tattoo.
That student may be driven to
believe in the equation just
by the matter of the fact
that it's authority.
But then making a
story makes--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the teacher makes himself
more human and makes one of
the people who invented the
Hardy-Weinberg equilibrium
more human.
So it's actually something
much more easy for the
students to connect to.
Yes, can you tell
me your name?
AUDIENCE: Gregor.
PROFESSOR: Gregor.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So my problem is that two
different options are very,
very different.
And the amount of legwork it is,
it's maybe more tense to
me, because you can discuss it
without legwork, but I think
also that option A is pretty
interesting, because you can
approach this biological
problem from more of a
qualitative approach.
So depending on what kind of
learner you have and what kind
of question you choose,
A would be also very
interesting.
But at that point, with the
background I have right now,
it's very difficult
to pursue that.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So Gregor's point, which is a
good one, is that B doesn't
have the same quantitative depth
as A. And actually, what
I'm going to show you is a way
to get to this starting from
here and using the principles
that we're talking about so
that by the time you get here,
or to something like this, it
actually makes sense
to the students--
so that you can have both.
So that's a promise.
And hopefully, I'll deliver
on it for you.
But does that address what
you're talking about?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: --that B doesn't have
the quantitative depth--
and that's true.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I mean, you
can talk about one hour on
B. But if you really want to
deliver an idea or a concept,
that is as quantitative as
option A, then you have to get
to A at some point.
PROFESSOR: So the point made
is that if you want to get
here, you do have to say
this at some point.
You can't just say the
story for now.
Well, it depends on the
purpose of the class.
If the purpose is the history
of biology, maybe you'd
continue with the story or the
history of science and war.
But if you want students to be
able to solve problems in
genetics, maybe you
need to go here.
Or what we'll find is I'll
continue with option B moving
towards A. And I'm going to show
how you can get there and
still have the opening
of B preserved.
OK so let's see.
There was--
yes.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Roger.
I think one of the reasons
we like B is because we
see A all the time.
So I don't know to what extent
that's [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So B is new.
Right.
So against A, A is very
familiar and common.
So in fact, yeah,
I chose this--
I didn't really make
a straw man here.
This is how a lot of things
are introduced.
For example, in mathematics
class, theorem proof--
so the theorem will be
introduced without any of the
struggle, the wondering that
led to the theorem.
Why would anyone even care
about such a thing?
Or if they cared about it, why
would they come up with
something like that?
How can you see that?
So yeah, A is seems very
familiar and therefore, maybe
not as interesting.
Although, it may also be
intrinsically less interesting
for the other reasons.
But I take your point, too,
that it could be just
familiarity.
Yes.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm Meg.
PROFESSOR: Meg.
AUDIENCE: It seems that you
could really incorporate the
quantitative side into B if you
wanted to by having the
way the proof occurred
[INAUDIBLE].
And then you wind up reversing
the traditional order, where
you have a proof and then a
theorem, because the way it
happened in reality and the
way it happens when you're
going to do research, and the
way it happens to students
when they're trying to work
it out themselves.
And so I feel like that's much
more of a natural flow
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So your point, which is an
excellent one as well, is that
B doesn't preclude
the quantitative.
What you could do is you could
talk about the history, start
with the history of Hardy saying
that, which is not
chronological, because
he said that in 1940.
But that's OK.
It doesn't have to chronological
just because
it's history.
Go to 1940 and then backtrack to
well, how did this problem
actually come to Hardy's
attention, which actually
turns out to be quite an
interesting story.
And then talk about how they
solved it and what was the
publication history.
And all the quantitative ideas
would come out in that way.
And it would be almost backwards
from the usual way.
The usual way here is
completely general.
And that's probably not the way
it was first figured out.
And the advantage of telling
about it that way is that
you're preparing students
themselves for a research
career, because nobody comes
up with theorems full blown
like Athena out of
the head of Zeus.
You come to them from struggle
and wondering.
Hm, I wonder.
Everything has some historical
background to it.
So it's called the, you could
say, the genetic approach.
So in biology, there's a slight,
not misconception, but
a saying that ontology
recapitulates phylogeny--
in other words, that the
organism, as it develops, say,
in the womb, goes through all
the evolutionary stages that
it went through over the last
200 million years or whatever
to become, say, a person.
You're at first a fish and then
maybe you're a monkey and
then you're a person.
So roughly speaking-- it's
not exactly true.
But there's a lot of truth to
that for learning ideas--
that you have to recapitulate
the history of ideas to really
understand where we are
now, the ideas today.
So a great example of that is
Newton's Second Law of Motion,
the idea that force and
acceleration are connected.
So for thousands of years,
millions of years, people
thought force and velocity
were connected.
And it's actually force
and acceleration.
So actually, you can guide
people to the understanding of
force and acceleration being
connected by showing them the
history of how people thought
it was force and velocity,
because for those same reasons,
those are the reasons
that students will
think it, too.
So you're actually helping
them overcome their
misconceptions.
So the history actually,
generally speaking, helps
overcome misconceptions.
So I'll put that here.
And the history is actually
quite interesting.
I think it was Punnett
from Punnett squares.
He played cricket with Hardy
and Hardy loved cricket.
And he just asked him
about this problem.
And Hardy said, oh.
Yeah, no, it's just this,
and sent off a paper
to Science or Nature.
So basically, it's because
they were cricket playing
colleagues in Cambridge, that's
how a mathematician
ended up interested in
a biology problem.
Punnett was a biologist.
OK.
So any other reasons?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm going to
play devil's advocate
for a second here.
PROFESSOR: Sure.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Paul.
PROFESSOR: Paul.
AUDIENCE: So when I had
biochemistry the first time,
the first month of the class,
the teacher would tell the
history about the people
developing quantum mechanics.
And that was the lectures.
We didn't touch the
material one bit.
And because his philosophy was
the material was in the book,
you don't need to teach it.
You just go home and read it.
But I remember being in that
class-- and maybe that's
because I normally don't see
things taught like that-- but
everyone was outraged,
because we didn't
feel we learned anything.
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So the comment is that you were
in an actual class that
was purely taught about
the history.
People were outraged.
They felt they weren't learning
actual content.
And there's two answers
to that.
One is that actually, I don't
recommend if, say, you're
teaching a physics class,
that you teach it purely
historically.
But to the extent that you do
teach the history, you can
actually teach the content
through the history.
So it's not that the history and
the equations or the ideas
are separate.
It's that you can use the
history as a means of making
the equations come alive with
a deeper understanding.
So it's possible that the
teacher you're talking about
actually didn't do that and just
talked about the people
who did this and did that.
But he didn't really know
what they did or why.
So you're not forced
to do that.
OK.
So I'll give you an example.
I'll continue with this in just
a moment after I take any
other questions, showing you
how you can start with the
history, and then you can
show the content.
You can actually show
people exactly why
that would be true.
And I'll show you that
in one second.
OK.
There was a question there.
Yes.
Sharon.
Oh, sorry.
Not Sharon.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Me?
PROFESSOR: No, in front.
AUDIENCE: Cecilia.
PROFESSOR: Cecilia.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering that
Option B-- it's like targeting
another audience.
I come to a class and I'm not
very interested in the class.
I need to be motivated here,
Genetics or something.
If I already signed
up for genetics--
because if I were being in a
class interested in that, I
actually want to learn things.
I want to know the rules.
So I don't know if I want
to be distracted by
some story that is--
when you first said that, I was
like, oh my god, if this
is going to be some other big
story, he's going to have the
equation at the end.
I'm not going to be
understanding what's going on
or whatever you say.
And I think that could be a
little bit of a turn off more,
because-- try to make
it look easy.
You have avoided writing the
equation on the board.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'm going
to do that next.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And also, I guess there
are two kinds of
stories you can tell.
I don't know what story you're
going to tell exactly, but
this seems to be removed from
the actual equation.
This is more Hardy's
philosophy.
It's not really--
PROFESSOR: It's not directly
about that.
AUDIENCE: Something you did a
second ago was more about the
equation and more about
the concepts
involved with the equation.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
So one question is how related
should the stories be?
And there's a lot of
freedom in that.
I would say the answer
is that you want it--
if it does this, if it creates
interest, then it's already
done something.
Now, your other point was that
it depends on the audience.
Suppose the audience is all
graduate students in genetics
or people who want a crash
course in genetics.
Maybe actually, they want to
just know the formula.
And they would actually be
offended if you started
telling them stuff that wasn't
the formula, because they feel
like they're time's
being wasted--
a little bit like what
you were saying.
So now, did you have a
comment about that?
AUDIENCE: No.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Then I'll come to
you one second.
So one comment about that is
that actually, most of the
students, at least in a big
class in genetics, are going
to be students who are--
for example, at MIT--
are there not because they love
genetics and are going to
continue in genetics.
They're doing it because they're
required to take
introductory biology.
And your job as a teacher is
to actually show them that
this is a really fascinating
subject.
It's the same in physics.
It's often taught as if the
only students in a physics
class were the physics majors.
Now, when I was an undergraduate
in Standford,
there were 1,600 undergraduates
and 12 physics
majors every year.
So 1% of the student body
was physics majors.
So they were actually teaching
in a way, generally speaking,
for 1% of the student body.
What about the other 99%?
It was really important for them
to reach them as well--
important, also, for the health
and growth of the
field, because the field needed
people who, even if
they weren't professional
physicists, saw the value in
the field and the value
in physics.
So generally speaking, it is
actually a wise way to reach
all of them.
Now, suppose you have people
who just want this.
The next thing I'm going to
do will show you a way of
teaching to them that they'll
actually learn this better,
because I guarantee you, almost
everyone, if you just
tell them this and they take
dictation, now they go away,
and you say, OK, everybody,
what did I write down?
Most people can't
reconstruct it.
They'll say, well, was
this a C or an N?
In fact, if you look in
Wikipedia, the Wikipedia entry
is incorrect.
Actually, I think it
has an N over here.
It seems plausible, but if you
actually understand the
equation, you think, that
can't possibly be right.
And I think it has
an N over here.
So they actually do
not really have a
command of the equation.
So even for them, you
want to not--
the story isn't the proof
of it for them, but the
continuation will be
valuable for them.
So again, I'll promise that.
Now, there was a question
over there.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: The story, you can
basically use to-- and if you
see you lose your students
when you go on this
quantitative approach, then it's
maybe helpful to loosen
up a little bit and basically
bought you interest to see
what's a big context.
And the other point was--
PROFESSOR: So you're first point
was that you can add
stories as needed.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
So depending on what
it's like.
And the other thing is when I
make my comments related to
the problem, I see it
more from a various
student point of view.
So you point out that, depending
on what the audience
is, you teach differently.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's true.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So when you
give your examples--
PROFESSOR: Oh, I should tell
you who the audience is.
AUDIENCE: --interesting to know
at a certain point what
kind of audience it was.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
Good point.
AUDIENCE: So I'm undergrad.
So I don't know how it is to
teach first year university.
I've never had students.
So how much basics or how much
story you have to put in
compared to how much math.
So it would be very helpful
to see what our target is.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Your comment is that it would be
helpful when I'll give you
an example like this to say,
OK, for the particular
audience, what would you do?
Yeah.
And I'll try to do that.
That's a good point.
Now, there was another
question--
behind Cecilia.
Did you still have a comment?
AUDIENCE: Oh, I just wanted to
mention that in choice A,
there's a lot of jargon.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So there's a lot of jargon in
choice A, which makes it much
harder to understand.
You have almost--
for example, the multinomial
coefficient--
you have to keep that in your
head, as well as all these
subscripts, keep it all in
your hand and try to
manipulate that object--
very difficult.
One of the points about that
related is the chunking.
So the chunking paper--
the idea is that these, for a
student, each of these things
is going to fill up one of the
chunk slots, almost, because
it's all new to them.
You've flooded the
chunking system.
You've overflowed it.
And they can't actually
manipulate this as one object
anymore, because it's
far too many chunks.
Now, you, as a professional
in the field, are
like, well, of course.
It's a multinomial
coefficient.
What else could it be?
For you, that's one chunk.
For the student, that's
is it C or N?
K1?
K?
Why K?
What the hell is K here?
Is it commas or spaces?
Parentheses?
What about brackets?
I've never seen something
like that.
Shouldn't there be as many
things up here as here?
So the way they look at it
is completely different.
Every symbol is almost
a chunk.
So this is just massively
overflowing with chunking.
So this is sort of related
to the jargon.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Scott.
PROFESSOR: Scott.
AUDIENCE: I have
a meta comment.
In this example, if you don't
know how you're actually going
to complete these, it's created
a lot of tension.
I'm dying to know how you're
going to do it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Fair enough.
Would you be very offended if I
gave everyone a break for a
few minutes and then
finished it?
AUDIENCE: OK--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So finish your comment.
AUDIENCE: My question is in a
situation like this where you
have people who are making so
many comments, and the other
half's just dying to know, how
do you know when to stop?
PROFESSOR: Good question.
So how do I know when to stop?
Because I don't want to exhaust
people's patience, but
I do want to take questions.
And in this case, there's the
American teaching phrase saved
by the bell, which is that
I don't have to make the
decision too hard, because
it's probably
time for a break anyway.
But how do I make
the decision?
Partly, I listen to
people's comments.
For example, suppose I got yet
another comment saying, well,
we still don't know
the equation.
And I'm saying for the
third time, oh, wait.
I'll show you a way to
get to the equation.
I think, you know, it's probably
time for me to do the
equation and then I'll take
more questions later.
So listen for the tension in
people's voice, which is also
a good reason to have everyone
do the voice exercise first
and free the tension so that if
the tension creeps back in,
you know it's something
you've done.
OK.
So I'll take more questions
after the break.
But it's 10:02 by that clock.
10:05, we'll start again.
You can jump up and down, do
jumping jacks or whatever it
takes to get the
blood flowing.
I'll take a couple more
questions and then I'll show
you how to continue it to
get towards that in
a perceptive way.
OK.
So let me, as promised, continue
along the lines--
not continuing the story, but
continuing that approach, the
alternative mirror image
approach of A, which is to
say, well, what would I do
after telling the story?
So first of all, I would try to
fix some of the problems in
just basically blasting
people with that.
So I try to make it as clear and
unjargony as possible-- so
as you notice, jargon
up there.
So imagine a gene with
two flavors--
sickle cell or not.
And two chromosomes--
so just like people have two
copies of each chromosome.
OK.
So now, before I continue,
what have I done
just by doing that?
Well, first of all, I've made
something concrete.
It's sickle cell or not.
So right away, you
can imagine it.
So that's continuing the
idea of a story.
It's much easier to imagine
a concrete situation.
Either you have sickle cell
anemia or you don't.
Or you have a gene for it or a
gene that doesn't cause it.
And the two chromosomes--
so rather than having C
chromosomes, I'm just
restricting it to two.
Now, you might think, well,
that's a terrible restriction.
That's a specialization.
Therefore, it's bad.
No.
Actually, it's good for that
reason, because it makes it
possible to understand, in the
next step, the idea behind
that equation.
And once you understand the
idea, then that equation is
not so mysterious.
And furthermore, what's nice
about two chromosomes?
Yeah, it's a specialization,
but--
AUDIENCE: Same two.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we
all have two.
There's some plants that have
more and some plants have
less, I think.
But people have two.
So it's already interesting to
us just for that reason.
OK.
So then the question is how
frequent are the combinations?
So we want to answer how
frequent are the three
combinations sickle--
lowercase S is not sickle.
So this is S. This
is lowercase S.
What happened to the
fourth combination?
Why are there only three?
Yeah.
It's the same.
S, S--
this and this are the same.
OK So I would actually
ask that, too.
Any time there's something
interesting--
it should have been four.
Plausibly, it could have been
four, but it's actually three.
Why three?
OK, it's because we're actually
lumping these two together.
OK.
So how frequent are those
three combinations?
Well, that's provided
by this formula.
P squared, q squared, 2pq--
so p and q are the frequencies
of S and little S.
So this is the--
OK.
So now, because you've asked
them about the three versus
four, this two makes sense,
already somehow.
But how could make
sense of the p
squared, pq, and q squared?
And so that's where I would
continue with the following,
which is this.
So here is 0 to 1.
And this is p.
And that's q.
So this is the frequency
of sickle cell.
This is the frequency
of not sickle cell.
So right away, you have
p plus q equals 1.
I'll draw this up here too.
So I make a square.
And I have four regions.
So it's not magic.
Why am I making a square?
What about the problem
tells me square?
So I would ask the class that.
I'm looking for area.
And why an area?
Why two dimensions?
AUDIENCE: Because there
are two chromosomes?
PROFESSOR: Because there
are two chromosomes.
So this is your C. The number
of dimensions is eventually
going to become this thing, so
you can see how we're going to
get there eventually.
So I'm looking for an area,
because I have two
chromosomes.
So now, let's just look at
these various areas.
Here's a p squared.
What's this area?
There's q by p.
So that's a pq.
That's also pq.
And that's q squared.
OK.
Let's look at all our pieces.
Oh, we have a p squared there.
We have a q squared there.
Oh, and pq, pq--
2pq.
So in fact, this picture
explains the entire set of
frequencies here.
And if you see this picture,
there's nothing really new to
understand here.
In fact, all this picture
is showing is that--
it's a picture of p plus
q squared equals 1.
So if p plus q is 1, its square
is also equal to 1.
And you break this up into the
four terms, group two of them
together, and you get
three terms, three
different kinds of terms.
You get three different
frequencies.
So now, this square is actually
very easy to use.
Suppose someone tells you that
sickle cell anemia, people who
have both genes, are 1%
in the population.
Well, what fraction of the
population has no sickle cell
gene that all?
OK.
Well, we can just look
at the square.
The information was
that this is 1%.
So that means this 0.1.
And that's 0.9.
That's 0.9.
So this here is people with
no sickle cell at all.
It is 0.81.
And so the square actually makes
everything really easy
to understand.
So now, the question is how
do you generalize it?
Well, what are some of the-- the
first generalization I'll
do is I'll say, suppose
that there are--
well, I'll ask you.
Should I generalize it to more
dimensions or more different
copies of the gene?
What's easier to draw?
More copies, because
more dimensions--
I don't know how to draw
in three dimensions.
But I can draw three copies.
That's pretty easy.
So now, take a piece of paper
and just on your own, draw
this same figure for three
copies of the gene with
frequencies p, q, and r.
So people have a picture?
Does anyone want to describe
their picture to me?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I did a three by three
square with p squared
and q squared and r squared
diagonal [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So I do the same.
I make a p, a q, and an r.
And then I do the same here--
qr.
OK.
So there's a p squared,
q squared, r squared.
Now, how many guys-- so we have
nine square, sub squares.
Three of them are this.
There's six more.
Now, which of them
look similar?
So this is a pq.
Are there any other pq's?
Yeah, one other, right?
pq over here. .
And here is a pr.
Is there a pr?
Yea, another pr over here.
And here's a qr and a qr.
So we have p squared.
And that's that guy.
We have q squared, r squared,
and then 2pr, 2qr, and 2pq.
So that's the generalization to
three copies of the gene.
So it turns out that all
these coefficients--
1, 1, 1, 2, 2, 2--
those are binomial, multinomial
coefficients.
So now, let's generalize
one more.
So what have we done?
There, before, we've
written out this.
And those are the nine terms
grouped into six.
So this was our C. So now, we
know how to generalize.
p plus q plus r to
the C equals 1.
If this is two chromosomes--
this is C chromosomes.
So this is C chromosomes
with three copies.
Well, what happens if
we have n copies?
p1 plus p2 plus one of those
plus pn to the C equals 1.
And all you have to do
is expand that out.
You can use a square in
higher dimensions.
Or you can actually use
formulas for math.
And that's where these
come from--
p1 to the 1 power, p2 to the
next power, all the way to pn
to the next power.
And these guys are the
coefficients that count the
multiplicity.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Why do you have
to add up to 1?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
They have to add up to 1 because
p plus q plus r, if
you only have three flavors of
the gene-- either you have
sickle cell A, B, or
C, let's say--
then these are probabilities,
probability p.
AUDIENCE: Oh, so parentheses
says how often it's done?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Frequency and probability--
so p plus q plus r equals 1.
So if you square it,
you still get 1.
So you start from the idea that
p plus q equals 1, which
is what we did over here.
So p plus q is equal to 1.
Then you square it.
It's still equal to 1.
So now, you just another
way of writing 1.
So it turns out that
Hardy-Weinberg is all just
fancy ways of writing 1.
Starting from this
picture, we've
successively complicated it.
This is C equals
2, n equals 2.
There's C equals
2, n equals 3.
Here is the same thing again.
Here is n equals 3, general C.
Here's general n, general C.
OK so what we've done is we've
basically got here--
by stages of successive
approach, one step at a time.
So at every stage, it's clear
what is going on.
And what's the core idea?
The core idea is the one you
just asked a question about,
which is that the frequencies
add up to 1--
p plus q equals 1-- so if you
square the frequencies, you
still get 1.
And there's nothing more to
Hardy-Weinberg than that.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I'm Julie.
PROFESSOR: Julie.
AUDIENCE: My question has to do
with the original way you
presented the problem--
using the word
flavors instead of alleles.
And I've always been fond of
teaching that you should
always use the probable
vocabulary of your students.
PROFESSOR: To switch.
AUDIENCE: So you got the
same thing as the--
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
good question.
So I used flavors instead
of alleles--
so right here, imagine a
gene with two flavors.
So actually, probably the
best way to do it is
to combine the two.
So you say flavors, because--
so this is a question of
transmitting information to
the student without noise
on the channel.
So if you say the
word allele--
so this is again related
to chunking.
If you say the word allele,
the problem is that now,
you're expecting them to try to
understand this new idea as
well as this new item for taking
up one of their chunks
that they have available.
So when I initially presented
it, I would use flavors.
And then I'd say, OK, now we
understand the whole idea.
The thing has kind of seeped--
it's not really part of short
term memory anymore.
It's connected to something
else that they know-- for
example, this. p plus q
equals 1, so p plus q
squared equals 1.
Now, it's not taking up so
many chunks anymore.
Now, they're ready to hear
the word allele.
So I'll say, OK.
Colloquially, we could say
flavors, but actually, the
word in the literature
is alleles.
So at no point, you're
overloading the system.
So again, it's philosophy
based on,
say, history and chunking.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you presented
this whole second way, you
made, actually, use of
the equation that you
wrote down in the--
PROFESSOR: Oh, over there?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Oh, no.
I was just saying that
for your benefit.
AUDIENCE: But I thought,
actually, for me, it was very
useful to see what the
kind of equation was.
And then as you were going
through the argument, I could
reason out myself--
PROFESSOR: Good question,
good point.
AUDIENCE: --where everything
was coming from.
PROFESSOR: Yeah OK.
That's a good point.
So it actually was helpful to
actually see the final goal to
know where you're going.
Actually, that's a
good suggestion.
It's actually not bad to say,
OK, this is what we're going
to try to understand.
I don't expect to understand
it now.
It's full of all kinds
of squigglies.
So for example, maybe a really
good way to do the whole thing
would be to start with the Hardy
story and say, we're
going to talk about
Hardy-Weinberg.
Say, what does Hardy-Weinberg
say?
Well, in its full generality,
it says, blah.
I don't expect you to make any
sense of that right now.
Let's talk about what the
core ideas of it are.
With this, you approach it,
creep up on it bit by bit,
successive generalization,
and then you get there.
So actually, it's a good idea.
Leave that on the board the
whole time so you have a
context and a goal, like
a mountain peak
you're trying to scale.
Thanks for the suggestion.
Yes.
Tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Scott.
PROFESSOR: Scott.
AUDIENCE: Last week, you did
present an example where you
wrote down this complicated
physics--
PROFESSOR: The Navier-Stokes
equation.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, you wrote down
the Navier-Stokes equation,
and then you said, yeah, I
sometimes do that just to
create this tension in the
students [INAUDIBLE].
So given that when you complete
this method-- you
actually didn't use
the story at all.
It seems to me that if you had
presented that and then you
stood back and made a joke about
[INAUDIBLE], it would
have been perfectly
satisfactory.
PROFESSOR: I think
that's true, too.
So a lot of teaching is
preference of the instructor.
I, for example, happen to really
like that story because
I taught in Cambridge for a long
time and I can imagine
Hardy running into Punnett
at the cricket ground.
So it's interesting to me, so I
can tell it with enthusiasm.
And I think it says something
about the relation of science
on society, which I
think is important
for students to learn.
So I might use that story.
But an instructor with different
purpose might do it,
as you say, which is make a joke
about how impenetrable
this is and say, it seems really
cryptic, but we'll
actually understand
this by the end.
Don't worry.
And that's a good way
of-- actually, I
think you're right.
It's a good way of creating
and releasing tension.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Eric.
PROFESSOR: Eric.
AUDIENCE: So what level of
background do we assume the
audience has?
Because you use sickle cell as
an example, and it's obviously
not critical to the example
that they know
what sickle cell is.
Do you assume that
they know that?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what level of background?
So if they don't know what
sickle cell is, or maybe I'd
use cystic fibrosis, which
they're maybe even
less likely to know.
AUDIENCE: --presentation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I could be adding noise.
So it's a flip side.
It's a two edged sword.
So are you adding noise by
saying sickle cell to someone
who doesn't know what it is?
Yeah.
It would add noise.
So maybe it's actually worth
saying just one sentence.
What is sickle cell anemia?
It's a mutation of the red blood
cells that makes them
take a different shape and makes
you unable to transfer
oxygen as effectively
and makes you more
resistant to malaria.
So actually, that part, I
wouldn't say at the beginning.
I'd say, well, if
it's so bad--
can't transport oxygen
so well--
how come it's still around?
Just let people think about that
for the day and come back
the next time and tell
them the answer.
But yeah.
So I'd probably say one sentence
if the people haven't
heard of sickle cell.
When I was saying it, I was
assuming mentally that they
know what it is.
But I think you're right.
Many people wouldn't know what
sickle cell anemia is, and
it's worth saying just
one sentence.
So let me just see if there's
anyone who hasn't made a
comment or question.
Yes.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Could you point to the
last little bit, because
I'm curious to see
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, how do
you get this piece?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So how do you get this
whole thing?
OK.
So let me do that by analogy.
So for example, suppose--
let me do C equals 3.
I'm running out of board.
Let me erase this one.
And in fact, let me just use n
equals 2, because it doesn't
illustrate any new ideas
to crank n up.
But the cranking the c up, the
number of copies, actually
makes it important to see why
you need to add them all up.
So let's do p plus q cubed.
So this is an organism with
three chromosomes.
But it's either sickle cell
or not at each spot.
OK.
Well, let's actually just
write this whole thing.
You could do it by looking at
a cube and seeing all the
chunks, because you could
actually just do it with
algebra, too.
So there's a p cubed.
There's a ppq.
So there's a ppq,
pqp, and qpp.
So those are all contributing
to p squared q, and there's
three of them.
OK.
Now, the three isn't what
we're talking about.
We're talking about this
exponent here.
Why is K1 all the way
up to Kn equal to C?
Well, let me just put
that 1 in there.
What does this equal?
The sum of those guys is 3.
That's p to the cubed
q to the 0.
That's also 3.
What's the next term?
Well, there's a 3
p cubed squared,
and there's a q cubed.
Well, that's q cubed
p to the 0.
That's 0 plus 3.
This is 1 plus 2.
It's always three.
And it's always the
C. Why is that?
Well, you only have
three products--
p plus q.
So you have three factors.
And you get to choose, when
you're writing out all the
terms-- there are eight of them
and we've combined them
into four groups.
There's three here, three here,
one here, and one there.
You get one from each
of the factors.
So you get one exponent
from each factor.
So the total of all the
exponents has to be 3.
So once you understand it
for 3, then this is
just for C in general.
Does that help?
So that's a good example,
actually.
Someone probably would ask that
question or should ask
that question.
And that's how I would
answer it.
OK.
Now, Cecilia, you had
another question.
Yes.
Did you have another question?
AUDIENCE: What are we proving?
For example--
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You'd think, on one hand,
what are we proving?
Well, we just proved p plus
q plus r squared equals 1.
So it looks like there's
no content.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: How has that
done anything?
AUDIENCE: The key fact is how
you prove that the 1, the 3,
the 3, and the 1 in
each [INAUDIBLE].
For example, are we supposed
to prove that
today or break even?
PROFESSOR: Well, I would say
there's no less information--
well, what we've learned is
that, for example, we've
learned this.
Why are there various
products here?
And then what this thing is--
we've learned intuitively what
this thing does.
This thing counts for the
number of copies.
So in the original--
n equals 2, C equals 2--
it was either there's two copies
or one copy of each of
these guys.
So it adjusted for the
number of copies.
When you have p plus q plus
r, there's one copy,
one copy, one copy.
There's two copies of that
one, two of that
one, two of that one.
So it's that factor.
It's the number of
copies factor.
And then in probability course,
you learn how to count
those factors in terms
of factorials.
And that has a definition
in terms of factorials.
But I wouldn't focus, for
example, in a biology course
on why it's factorials,
necessarily.
I'd want them to understand that
this thing counts for the
number of factors.
But actually calculating the
number of factors for general
C and n wouldn't be my first
goal in the course.
AUDIENCE: So if I didn't have
that in mind, why would I--
so the general purpose is
teaching the terms in the
multinomial expression.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's terms in a multinomial
expansion--
so basically, it's from writing
out 1 equals 1.
So it seems like, oh my god,
we've done nothing.
What have we learned?
We've just learned 1 equals
1, which we already knew.
But actually, by splitting up
1 on the other side, you've
actually given meaning
to each of the terms
on the other side.
So this is the frequency of
probability of having three
copies of gene type A and
none of the other type.
This is the probability of
having two copies of gene A
and one of gene B. And this is
the probability of having one
of gene A and two of gene B.
So there are three, because
there's different
ways of doing it.
AUDIENCE: So do you have these
chromosomes with different
flavors [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That's right.
Because these organisms we're
talking about come with
multiple copies of
chromosomes.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What is that?
Yeah.
So what's the phenotype
in the end?
And you're right.
So with the sickle cell-- so
actually, that is an advantage.
So the point is you
need to link this
phenotype and the genotype.
And that's true, actually.
I've erased the sickle cell, but
actually, the sickle cell
is a good example
for doing that.
If you have no copies of the
sickle cell gene, then you're
perfectly healthy.
If you have two copies of the
sickle cell gene, you have
sickle cell anemia.
What happens if you have one
copy of the sickle cell gene?
Well, you do have some
symptoms of it.
So the question is why does
that gene survive?
Well, it's because
you're actually
more malaria resistant.
At least, that's one
of the theories.
So somehow, I guess the malaria
parasites can't eat
those red blood cells as well
because they have a different
shape or can't invade it.
So it actually gives you
some advantage and some
disadvantage, but they're
sort of balanced.
And yeah, if you have full blown
sickle cell with two
sickle cell genes, then
you're in trouble.
But that's much rarer than
the 2pq, as long
as q is small enough.
So then you can actually
continue that example.
You can look at the frequency
of sickle cell gene in
different populations and say,
OK, well, is it higher in
areas where there's malaria?
And test that theory.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I noticed that the
first one that you did was to
stay mathematical with
the number line.
When I've, in the past, taught
[INAUDIBLE], I always stick
with conceptual--
p is this allele, and
then you've got a
phenotype in the end.
I'm just wondering if you chose
this because you know
that you're teaching mostly to
people with math rather than
scientists.
And if you were teaching to,
say, English majors--
PROFESSOR: Good question.
Yeah, so I think you're right.
I did this kind of
mathematically, compared to
maybe how you've taught it
to biology students.
And yeah, I guess I'm implicitly
assuming-- but I
didn't say, and I should say--
that this is MIT students.
I'm just, in the back of mind,
thinking MIT students.
But I didn't make that
assumption explicit.
So MIT students are perfectly
happy with squaring binomials
and trinomials--
trinomials, usually.
And to the C power--
sort of stretching
it, but it's OK.
But generally, that way of doing
things for them is good.
If it's people, English majors,
yeah, you're right.
I would try to actually do
even more conceptually.
But one thing that's good for
all of them is the picture,
because once you see the
picture, then you actually
understand the idea
in one grasp.
It's really just
one chunk now.
Oh.
It's just a square
in four pieces.
Oh, OK.
It's just a different
way of writing 1.
This is one area 1 and
there's four pieces.
So that I would keep, no matter
who I would talk to.
And the question is how much
would lead up to it?
Yes
AUDIENCE: So I think I just had
an idea here that I think
highlights why you can't just
go in with this, because
there's a disconnect
between what these
terms mean at the end.
PROFESSOR: Why you can't
go in with A.
AUDIENCE: Right.
So I think you have to draw a
connection between, say, the
areas of the boxes in
the diagram and
the phenotype frequency.
PROFESSOR: You're right.
So what you're saying is that
you can't just launch in with
this, because even though
you could give--
say you gave really exact
definitions of what all these
things are.
It's not clear that exact
definitions are
computationally productive
for a student.
Yeah, they may have the exact
definitions, but they can't
actually use it.
For example, let's do an exact
definition of chess.
I'll tell you all the
rules of chess.
And that's enough of an exact
definition to be able to
decide what the best first
move in chess it.
But it's computationally
useless.
I still don't know what the best
first move is, even if I
know the rules of chess.
So just telling the student
all the rules that, say,
define what a genotype is and
what's polyploidy, doesn't
mean they can actually use
it in any problem.
So if you want to transfer, all
these things have to have
meaning for them.
And that's what the goal
of this approach is.
Now, I think the approach has
been improved from your
suggestions.
I just wanted to show you
a direction to go.
But I think you've actually
taken it farther and extended
it and improved upon it.
And the general principles
among all of them are
that you want to--
I would say one of the
key ones is chunking.
You want to not overload
the chunk system.
You want to somehow bring people
in so they'll even
listen to you.
If they don't listen to you,
if they don't care, the
learning is going to
be so much less.
So all those are for that.
So the dictation and jargon
oppose chunking.
And these all go together.
OK.
So now, what I want to do is
give you a short answer to one
of the questions that
was raised earlier.
How you become a good teacher?
The reason I want to
do that is that is
exactly the same thing--
if you understand how you become
a good teacher, you
understand how you become
good at anything--
how you become good at chess,
how you become good at
biology, how you become good at
solving physics problems,
how you become good at playing
concert piano.
So if that's what you want to
teach your students-- to be
good at those things-- well, you
want to understand that in
a context, say, that
you're working on--
say, being a good teacher.
And to do that, there is the
following set of experiments.
So projectors--
OK.
So the way I'm going to
illustrate this is I'm going
to show you a chess position.
And the goal is to try to
remember the chess position.
I'm going to give you
two more seconds.
OK.
So everyone got the position?
Now, I'm going to ask you
instead of to remember
exactly, to reconstruct it.
How many pawns were there?
That would be E.
So who votes for A?
OK.
Who votes for B, nine pawns?
Who votes for C, 11 pawns?
Who votes for D, 13 pawns?
Who votes for E, none
of the above?
OK.
So let me show you.
Then I'll explain why I asked
you this particular question.
So there are actually 11.
Now, it's a very hard task.
So this actually, this
very tasks--
not counting the number
of pawns--
I made that slight variation.
But the so-called reconstruction
task was given
to chess players of
various abilities.
Grandmaster slash master
is one group.
What are called experts--
experts are people who are not
quite chess masters, but
close, in chess lingo.
And then class A players,
which is pretty strong
tournament players.
So they were given the task of
looking at a position for four
to five seconds.
The position was knocked down,
and they were asked to
reconstruct it as accurately
as they could.
OK.
So it's even harder than
the task of counting
the number of pawns.
So the results are
very striking.
So by level of chess player--
so class A is the strong
tournament players, experts or
grand master or master.
So the percent correct--
51% of the pieces correct,
72% or 93%.
So the grand masters and the
masters were amazing.
And in fact, for the number of
pawns, I don't think they ever
make mistakes on that, because
pawns are one of things that
you just know as a really
strong chess player.
So 93% percent correct--
and that's amazing.
So there's an related story,
which is about the memory of
chess players, which is the
Bobby Fischer-- yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm thinking the
positions, the positions
wouldn't work.
It wasn't possible.
They wouldn't do it as well.
PROFESSOR: I'll come to
that in one second.
So Bobby Fischer was in a
tournament and some strong
master was playing in it.
And Bobby Fischer went
to the bathroom.
And as he went to the bathroom,
he happened to see
that master playing a game and
just continued walking.
And then about six months later,
he ran into him at
another tournament.
Fischer said to him, oh, in
that position in that
tournament, did you play blah?
And the guy said, well,
actually, I had no idea what
the position was, even.
Fischer said, oh, and he set up
the board and said, well,
see, this was the thing that
you really needed to do.
And by then, he sort
of remembered.
But Bobby Fischer remembered
at one
glance six months later.
So what's a natural conclusion
from this data?
You'd say, well, naturally,
grand masters and masters--
they were born with better
visual memory.
But in fact, the crucial
experiment was
then done in 1973.
So this experiment was done
in 1948 by de Groot.
What Chase and Simon did in
1973 was that they showed
positions that were random.
So they redid the experiment--
they confirmed these results.
And then, as you suggested,
they showed just positions
where the pieces were scattered
arbitrarily over the board.
And then everyone was basically
at 12%, give or take
1% or 2%, just random
variations.
So what does that show?
It's not that the--
maybe Bobby Fischer
was an exception.
But for almost everybody else,
even the very strongest
players, it's not that
they're born with a
better visual memory.
It's that they've learned
somehow a way of looking at
chess positions that there's
less to remember for them.
OK.
So now let's compare.
Here, when the student sees
this, there's a ton for the
student to remember, just like
when we look at a chess
position, every piece
is separate.
But what does a chess
player see?
When a chess master looks
at a chess position--
so I'll put the position back
and I'll show you what the
chess master sees.
The chess masters see something
very different.
They see groups of related
pieces together.
So for example, here, the
chess master sees--
this king here is not a
surprising thing for this
chess master.
That's when you castle
your king.
That's where it goes.
Then the rook goes next to it,
and then you usually move your
rook into the middle.
So that's not surprising.
This rook is also not
surprising, the second one,
because it usually comes from
this corner into the middle.
So all of this almost contains
no information
for the chess master.
Here, these three pawns are very
common, with the castled
king on that side.
But then it looks
kind of strange.
There's some new information
there, because maybe this king
castled, but then the
rook went all
the way to the corner.
So actually, maybe black
never castled.
And his kind just sort of
wandered into this area.
What does that suggest?
This suggests that the black
king is really vulnerable.
Maybe it's time for an attack.
And in fact, I'm pretty sure
this is a position from one of
Garry Kasparov's games.
And in fact, that is the
right conclusion.
The right conclusion is that
it's now time to sacrifice
your knight and take this pawn
and draw the king out.
And he actually won
using that--
by sacrificing his knight.
So the chess master looks at it
completely differently than
the novice.
I'm a novice when
I play chess.
To me, every piece is a new
bit of information.
I'm way overloaded past
my chunk threshold.
I can't hardly remember
the board at all.
So your students are in exactly
the same position when
they're learning material that,
for you, you're the
chess master.
So you're teaching
Hardy-Weinberg.
Well, clearly, you've been
appointed to teach
Hardy-Weinberg because you
have a Ph.D. In biology.
You know a lot of biology.
You're the biology master.
So this doesn't surprise
you that much.
But for the student, every
single almost letter in there
is news to them.
So what you want to do is you
want to find ways of thinking
about it that you can group
the ideas into chunks.
So here is almost one chunk--
for example, the idea
that really, it's
just p plus q squared.
And there's a picture for it.
And once you understand that,
there's another chunk.
There's another idea which is
well, you could actually have
three kinds of flavors
instead of two.
OK. p plus q plus 4--
oh, I can transfer it there.
Oh, and then once you understand
that, you can
transfer it to n flavors.
Now, you can increase the
number of copies of the
chromosome--
so into two dimensions,
three dimensions,
four dimensional picture.
So then, you can actually
make sense of all this.
You can have a way of
understanding the position.
And not too long ago, there's,
I think, a not well enough
known paper--
I'll put the reference
on the website--
which shows the relative
importance of symbolic
calculation versus perception.
So this is a perceptual mode.
So much of our teaching is,
let's say, left brain-- very,
very symbolic.
Well, there was this really
interesting study done of
chess grandmasters--
in fact, of the strongest
chess grandmaster
today, Garry Kasparov.
What's the relative importance
of perception versus analysis
in his really strong
chess playing?
So the way they tested that--
there was a really good
experiment--
is he would play simultaneous
exhibitions all the time.
So the way you do a simultaneous
exhibition is
there's, for example, let's
say, 10 opponents.
And you would just go around one
component after another.
They have the full time, say,
three minutes, to think until
you come back.
But as soon as you get to a
board, you just think for
about five or six seconds, maybe
10, and make a move, and
go to the next board, so that
by the time you come around
back to that same opponent,
they've had their couple
minutes to think.
So now, he played simultaneous
exhibitions against very
strong grandmasters.
And you can then measure
his performance there.
So why is that a good
experiment?
Well, he's now not able to do
all of his calculation that he
does normally.
He's normally able to think for
three minutes, maybe five
minutes, and do a whole bunch
of analysis, symbolic
computation.
But when he has five seconds,
10 seconds to think, mostly
it's perception.
Well, his chess rating
effectively dropped by maybe
50 or 60 points.
So 50 or 60 points, to
give you an idea--
his chest rating is the
highest in the world.
It dropped to a level which only
five people in the world
are higher.
So it's a very small drop.
So he still plays incredibly
strong chess, better than
almost every other grandmaster
on the planet.
So almost purely with
perception--
so what that shows is that the
way Kasparov has become so
good and in general, experts
have become so good is it they
look at the world different.
Their perception is different.
So how do you do that
as a teacher?
That's one question.
How do you promote that
in your students?
Well, you want to give the ways
of looking at the world
that change their perception.
That's why I'm so focused on
the story, the tension, the
human, the right brain, the
pictures, the chunking,
because it's those that are
actually producing long term
expertise, whereas this is
producing what would be the
equivalent of programming
a chess computer.
But that doesn't work.
That may work for chess
computers to play good chess.
But it doesn't actually work for
people to be able to use
the knowledge later.
So now, what produces that?
So there's one short answer
which is that for teaching,
you want to change your
perception of
how students think.
If you have a correct, new,
good perception of how
students are thinking, then
you're actually able to make
teaching judgments on the fly.
You can plan chess move, your
lecture, like a chess game.
Your intuition is right.
So you want to tune
your intuition.
Well, that is why I do this.
I've found the single most
important thing that has
improved my teaching, and I
highly recommend, is the
feedback sheet, because for
example, I learned what was
confusing in question one.
And in question two, I learned
what works and
what doesn't work.
So as I see what works and
doesn't work, I start to build
up a more and more accurate
model of you.
And I start to be able to plan
and reason about how to teach
you and, in general, how
to teach students.
So I'll talk about that more.
That's the idea of deliberate
practice and expertise.
I'm going to talk about that
more in the subsequent
sections in more detail and show
you some of the studies
around that.
But the general rules is you
want reflective, quick
feedback on what you're doing in
order to become an expert.
And that's true whether you're
in teaching, concert piano,
physics problems, whatever
it may be.
So with that said, if you can
fill out the sheets so that I
can become a better teacher,
that will be very helpful.
And one announcement, which is
that next week is a Tuesday.
MIT is open on Tuesday,
except it's
Monday's schedule of classes.
So we don't have a
class next week.
The week after that,
I'm a witness in an
administrative law trial.
So I'm not here.
So there's no class for
the next two weeks.
So we'll meet again
in three weeks.
And I'll post some readings and
a short problem set for
you to work on--
some readings growing out of
what we've done today.
OK.
So if you could bring up your
sheet and your index card to
separate piles, that would
be very helpful.
And there's going to be another
class coming in--
a big class, I think.
So I'll just go outside and
answer any questions that
people I have right outside
so that the new
class can come in.
SPEAKER: Answers from Lecture
3 to questions
generated in Lecture 2.
PROFESSOR: I'm going to first
answer questions from before,
since there are lots of
questions, and all
interesting.
And I'm also going to do another
equation example.
There was lots of requests for
another equation example to
see how it plays out in a
different field and a
different way of approaching
equations, not just from the
entry point of a story.
So I'll show you that.
And then we're going to look at
misconceptions in various
fields and the fundamental
importance of understanding
that so that you can understand
how to change your
teaching and how to reach
the students.
Basically, if you can't
understand where they are, you
can't come to them.
So questions from before--
one comment was that I don't
often enough summarize the end
result with the transferable
lessons for later.
So thanks for that suggestion.
I'll make sure to do that.
Another question was graduate
versus undergraduate classes.
We talked a fair amount about
audience a bit last time in
response to questions.
So how do you change your
teaching in response to
questions, in response to
the change in audience?
So the particular question
here is graduate verses
undergraduate classes.
And the sense I got from some
of the questions was that
somehow, it's harder to do what
we were talking about
last time, which is teaching
equations in an intuitive way,
in a graduate class than
a undergraduate class.
Actually, in some ways,
it's the opposite.
It's true that generally, in
graduate classes, people just
put up a ton of equations.
For example, in quantum field
theory, you just get a
gazillion integrals with
epsilons floating all over the
place and then path integrals.
You integrate this.
And there are some 2 pis and
you take a bunch of limits.
And it seems like a whole bunch
of methods gymnastics.
But A, it doesn't have
to be that way.
And also there's another
characteristic of graduate
students which you don't have
so much with undergraduates,
which is that graduate students
know how to read.
Now, this may seem like a
bizarre statement, because
surely, everyone knows how to
read by, say, age three or
four or five or whenever
they teach reading in
school these days.
But what I mean is that
undergraduates--
generally, they have no
experience on how to read a
textbook because they've had
so much experience with us
telling them stuff everything
on the board.
So they have no incentive to
actually read the textbook.
And they don't learn
how to do that.
They think textbooks are
read the way you
read Jane Austen novels.
You just read for plot.
Something happened to some
equation, then something else
happened to some equation.
And you just carry on, paragraph
by paragraph, as you
would a novel.
That way of reading is
completely hopeless for
technical material.
But graduate students--
not always, but generally--
have much more
maturity about this.
So graduate students actually
can or often are closer to
being able to read technical
material with skill.
For example, graduate students
often read papers
in their own field.
And you know you have to read
a paper differently than you
would a Jane Austen novel.
So because of that, you can
actually teach equations very
differently.
What you do is you give all the
long, messy, yucky parts--
you leave that for the notes,
for the book, somewhere where
everything is printed in a
very easy to read format,
rather than copying long, long,
long, long strings of
symbols off the board.
So that connects back so what
we talked about last time,
which is chunks.
So if you put long equations
up on the board, generally,
you overflow the chunk system.
And once that happens, people
start making mistakes.
So you want to avoid doing
that as much as possible.
And with graduate students,
it's even easier to do,
because you leave all that for
a type set, professionally
published book or type set by
yourself, but somehow printed
in a clean way with
no mistakes.
And you can then, in
class, discuss the
meaning of the terms.
What are the terms?
Where do they come from?
Why would you expect
that kind of term?
So I'll give you an example
of doing that
with an equation today.
But generally speaking, all of
what I was talking about last
time applies perfectly well to
graduate classes, even if
people at first think
that it doesn't.
So I should say if any questions
occur to you as I'm
answering questions--
basically, questioning beginning
questioning--
please raise your hand and
ask them right now.
OK.
I found that the square
diagram muddied the
development of the
Hardy-Weinberg equation.
So the square diagram
was this one.
So the conclusion from that was
the question-- which is
shouldn't college students be
comfortable with expanding p
plus q squared?
Why do they need a diagram?
And the answer isn't that people
aren't comfortable with
expanding p plus q squared,
although you will find people
for whom this and this is just a
symbol replacement strategy.
In other words, it's something
like you program in a computer
whenever you see this
pattern do this.
But the terms don't actually
have meaning for people.
They don't know why those
terms are that way.
And if they'd mismemorize and
put cubes here, they would
write that down too.
So the picture actually makes
it clear what the meaning of
the term is.
So it gives, actually, meaning
to what people might be
otherwise comfortable
with or having done
from lots of practice.
So I should say there's a
difference between just rote
matching between here and
here versus this kind of
understanding.
And that's illustrated by the
following research, which is
about people's ability to
multiply and add when people
have brain damage.
So the technical term
is brain lesions.
The people with brain
lesions in the--
let's see if I can
say this right.
Some people with brain lesions
in the arithmetic areas lose
their ability to add, but
they can multiply fine.
And people with brain lesions in
the verbal areas, they lose
their ability to multiply,
but they can add fine.
Now, this seems kind
of strange, right?
So why would multiplication
and addition to not go
together when you get brain
damage in the arithmetic area?
So if the damage is either an
arithmetic or verbal, here's
what you lose.
So arithmetic area damage,
you lose addition.
Here, you lose multiplication.
And that is very bizarre,
because you'd think you should
lose multiplication here, too.
And the reason that it doesn't
work that way is because of
the way multiplication is
generally learned and taught.
So for example, in England
the way it's taught is--
this is research from Brian
Butterworth in England.
The way multiplication is taught
in England is in the
multiplication table,
same is here.
And people memorize it
as six 9's is 54.
So six 9's is 54.
Here, I think I learned
multiplication both places.
So 6 times 9 is 54.
Either way, that's a purely
linguistic string.
It's no surprise that when you
lose verbal ability, you lose
the ability to memorize
linguistic strings.
So the multiplication
table went.
So what that tells you is that
most people-- and I don't know
if this is true for everyone,
but my guess is it depends on
how you learned the
multiplication table.
For most people, they learned
the multiplication table in a
way that is not meaningful.
They've learned the
multiplication table purely
linguistically.
And that is the problem with
just going down this path
only, which is that--
again, this is where it's
important to know where the
students come from.
If you know students basically
have just linguistically
memorized this transformation
to that transformation, like
the rock bands in
other countries
that sing in English.
They know when they
see English words.
They know what to say.
But they don't necessarily
understand any of the words.
That is actually very common.
And this is another linguistic
transformation.
There's no meaning
underneath it.
So here to give it some meaning
underneath it, some
picture, it actually
incorporates another brain
area into the understanding,
which is where addition
actually has some meaning
to people.
So that brings up a related
question, which is if people
have learned multiplication in
this linguistic way, how could
you teach it in a non linguistic
way so that people
actually understand it?
There are several ways.
I don't know of any studies that
show that after doing it
this way and then brain damage,
it doesn't get lost.
But my speculation is that if
you learn it, actually, pretty
much the way I learned it, you
wouldn't actually lose it.
And the way is, for example,
suppose you have to
multiply 6 times 9.
Rather than memorizing that
as 54, you think about
what it should be.
And you reason your way to it.
And we think, oh, well,
that's slower.
Yeah, it's slower in
the beginning.
But in the end, you get
to the same place.
But you've put it in a different
part of the brain.
So the way you could do
this one, for example,
you say 6 times 9.
That's 6 times 10, which is
really easy, minus 6.
So 6 times 10 you know not
by memorizing but from
understanding the
number system.
So you know that that's 60
because of the way the number
system works.
You don't have to
memorize that.
That's the kind of example
where I think calculators
should be programmed to self
destruct or at least not work
for about a week if you type
in a problem like that.
They should just freeze as an
incentive to actually think
about these things before you
put them into the calculator.
So minus 6, and you get 54.
So now, that's a bit longer
the first time you do it.
It's longer than
memorizing it.
But after you do multiplication
a bunch of
times like this, you actually
reinforce the meaning of the
number system, and you come
up with the same answer.
And eventually, you will
memorize it, but you've
memorized it in a
different way.
Here's another example.
From the 12 times tables--
8 times 12.
Now, should you memorize
that as 96?
No.
You should write that as 10
minus 2 times 10 plus 2.
So that's equal to 10 squared
minus 2 squared equals 96.
And you can even draw a picture
for this and show what
happens to squares and areas.
So again, you've come up with
the same answer, but you've
done it in a meaningful way.
So that's one answer to why it's
worth showing pictures,
even if people can
do the algebra.
It reinforces the algebra.
Is determining what constitutes
a chunk simply a
matter of my intuition about
students' level?
Well, to some extent, it is.
But in the chess playing
research I talked about, they
actually had more objective
ways of determining
what a chunk was.
And what they did is they put
eye trackers on people.
And they had the chess masters
and the non chess masters and
the experts look at the board,
and they tracked their eyes to
see what they did.
So the non chess masters, their
eyes wandered all over.
But the chess masters looked
at pieces in groups.
They would go here, here, here,
here, and then here,
here, here, here.
And the assumption was that
that's a chunk and
then that's a chunk.
Or if they went here then to
there, that somehow, these two
chunks were related.
So there was ways in the
chess playing problem
of measuring chunks.
And then how do you apply that
to, say, teaching physics?
Well, that's a matter,
partly, of intuition.
And the idea is to help the
students build up the chunks.
So you have to be on the watch
for what chunks you use.
So you have to introspect.
OK.
How do you keep things
interesting and reveal
material in a time
appropriate way?
So the comment was that it
took a while to do the
Hardy-Weinberg with the story
and then building up to it.
So this is a question of how
do you plan lecture time.
What's worth doing in lecture?
Is it worth spending
a bunch of time on
understanding the concepts?
And there's two extremes
to this.
I'm basically towards one
extreme, which is that if you
don't understand the concepts,
it's not even worth learning
the thing, because as a
student, if you don't
understand the concept, you
might as well just forget the
material right now, because
you're going to
forget it soon anyway.
So the only benefit from taking
the course if you don't
understand the material, is
you just get a great on a
final exam and you pass
a requirement.
But in terms of actually
changing how you see the
world, it ha no value.
So there was a study done, I
think, at Carnegie Mellon.
Yeah, this was at
Carnegie Mellon.
They studied freshman
physics students.
So they had students who took
freshman physics and students
who didn't take freshman
physics.
And then a year later, they gave
them the freshman physics
final exam--
I think it was the same one,
pretty much, as the students
who took freshman physics took,
except with numbers
changed, but otherwise,
it was same problems--
to see whether taking freshman
physics had any effect on
whether you did well on
a freshman physics
final a year later.
And the conclusion was that it
had no effect a year later.
So yeah, sure, if you're give
them the final the next day
after the final exam that they
took, they would have done
pretty well, maybe 50%.
Who knows what the
time constant is.
But certainly, by a
year, it was gone.
So what that tells me is that
that regular way of teaching
material actually did no good
to the students except for
passing a requirement, but no
intrinsic good for their way
of analyzing the world.
So what that says is then
you really need to
find something different.
And yeah, if it means it takes
extra time in lecture, a bunch
of time in lecture, so be it.
At least people will understand
something and they
will change how they
see the world.
And that's the motive for today,
which is to really
understand misconceptions,
because if you don't
understand the misconceptions,
you're not going to be able to
teach in a way that produces
long lasting learning.
OK.
So another one was how
do I apply this to
something really abstract?
The way of approaching
equations, like the proof of--
oh, this is actually one of my
favorite infinite series.
So the question is how do you
apply it to something really
abstract like this?
So this is a famous
infinite series.
What's the sum of that?
And it turns out to be
pi squared over 6.
Well, even that, you think,
well, how can
I apply it to that?
And it turns out there's great
stories about that one, too.
I think this is a story about
this problem, which is that no
one knew how to do this sum
from 1 to infinity.
It's quite a hard sum.
And so it was set as a problem,
basically, for the
mathematicians and physicists
of Europe.
And then someone produced
a solution.
I think someone produced
a solution anonymously.
And everyone basically figured
out who had done it, because
it had their handy mark.
So the solution was by Euler.
And it involved a whole bunch
of trickery with polynomials
and infinite degree
polynomials.
And it was a really
sly method.
So if I was going to teach
this equation, I would
actually teach the history of
it-- how was really hard, how
you could actually guess this.
What are ways you could
guess this?
Well, you could actually
approximate the sum, get a
number that's one or two or
three digits accurate.
And then you feed it into--
does everyone know this guy?
If you Google for that, you
should probably find it.
It's called the inverse
symbolic calculator.
It's a fantastic thing.
I do not know how it works.
And I would love to
know how it works.
But what it is is you feed in a
number, and it will tell you
all the ways of producing
something
really close to that.
So for example, if you put in
3.141, it'll say a bunch of
numbers that get near here.
And one of them is pi.
If you put in this to one or
two or three digits, it'll
probably guess for you
pi squared over 6.
So that's one way of getting
at an answer.
So part of the way of teaching
it is to say, well, let's
somehow get an answer
with ways we can do
that aren't too abstract.
And then let's see if we can
justify that answer.
So even there, you're
not lost.
There's always stuff
you can do.
Oh, another question, which
was readings-- how do you
incorporate readings into a
course so that students do it?
So that was asked twice,
actually, because I didn't
answer it the first time.
So one way to do readings
is something
called reading memos.
And it's an MIT invention by
Edwin Taylor, who's recently
retired from the physics
department.
And what a reading memo is--
I'll put up the handouts.
So I have often done
this in my classes.
I'll put up the handout for you
to use that I give out and
you can just copy it or
do whatever with it.
So a reading memo is a request
to the students to write you a
short memo about something
that you've
asked them to read.
It could be the draft notes for
your textbook that you're
working on, which is what
I often do it with.
Or it could be the textbook
someone else wrote and you ask
the students to read chapter.
And what it's not is it's not a
summary of the text, because
you already know what
the text says.
There's no point in
getting a summary.
What it is is students'
reactions to it.
So anything that questions,
things that puzzle them--
oh, I didn't understand
why you did this or
the author did this.
And then maybe three pages
later, oh, now, I see--
which, if you're the author of
those notes, you know that you
explain the two things
out of order and you
should connect them.
But what that does is it teaches
students how to read
actively, because again, I like
I talked about, people
just do Jane Austen's approach
to reading technical material.
And by getting students to read
actively and formulate
questions, by doing that,
students learn a different way
of reading, a way necessary for
reading technical material.
And also by writing their
questions down and you seeing
the questions, you actually
get a view into how the
students are thinking.
So it's actually a way of
understanding what their
misconceptions are, their
conceptions of the field are,
and tuning your teaching.
Just automatically, you'll
find your teaching will
impedance match to where the
students are just by reading
the reading memos.
It has a further benefit, which
is that it inverts the
normal power relationship
between teacher and student.
So for example, most
assignments, problem sets,
there's the correct answer,
which you know.
And you're seeing whether they
know the correct answer.
So they're now writing an
answer, worried whether
they're correct or not.
And then you're judging them.
So normally, p set, the power
hierarchy is you and then the
student down here.
And the student is looking
up to you for validation.
So now, this is not a
good thing to teach.
And maybe it's hard to avoid
with problem sets.
You have to do problems sets
somehow when you teach people
to do problems.
But you want to minimize this
as much as possible, because
it's not a transferable way
of dealing with the world.
They can't use that when
they go elsewhere.
And it teaches bad habits of
deference to authority.
So that's normal.
How does a reading memo work?
Well, it's the other
way around.
If the student says, this is
confusing, by definition, they
are correct.
It's confusing.
They are the expert on what's
confusing or not.
So it inverts the hierarchy
to this.
And you become very interested
in what the
students are saying.
They are the experts now.
And I've had very good results
with doing reading memos.
And my explanation is that it's
because of this inversion
of power hierarchy.
Now, what I mean also
by good results--
two things.
One is that I get fantastic
feedback on
the things I'm writing.
The other is that I find
students actually want to do
reading memos after the
class finishes.
They say, oh, if you have more
notes, can we just do some
more reading memos?
Great.
Let's do that.
And it's because
it's actually--
if you write the problem sets,
they'll often say, can we do
more problem sets?
But that requires a fair
amount of work to
minimize the hierarchy.
But it's automatically here
in the correct hierarchy.
So students actually
enjoy doing
that and want to continue.
So that's one excellent
way of incorporating
reading into class.
So now, the problem is, what you
do when you have 50 people
in a class and you
get 50 memos?
So I've had this problem.
And one thing I do is I just
feel overwhelmed and I just
flip through them but I
don't know what to do.
But another is I revise
my notes based on it.
But the I think correct solution
is an online system.
So what you want is an online
system where you can post a
PDF file, and then people make
comments on the PDF file.
So everyone gets to see an image
of the page, and they
can just click and
make a comment.
And everyone gets to see their
own comments, and then when
they submit them, they get to
see everyone else's comments.
So I actually wrote half
of that system.
And there's a graduate student
in EECS who I think has now
written a whole system
independently of me.
So I'm going to try it out and
see how it works and try it in
some of my classes
this semester.
So the benefit of that is that
you can then see all the
comments at once, rather than
flipping through 50 sets of
reading memos with page
numbers on them.
OK.
How do I come up with
intuition examples?
How do I know if what builds
intuition for me will also
build intuition for
the students?
It's a very good question.
Is it just my personal opinion
or is it just the teacher's
personal opinion?
One of the whole themes about
this class is yes, teaching
does have a fair amount of art
and there is a fair amount of
personal opinion in it.
But there's also a fair amount
of science and things you can
do to make it more objective.
And one of them is actually
to do reading memos.
Any way you can to learn how
students think will make it so
that your intuition about the
students actually matches how
the students really think.
That's the whole purpose of
today about talking about
misconceptions.
Reading memos are way
of understanding
what students think.
Oh, there they are--
the reading memos.
So once you understand what
students think, it's much
easier to realize, just
intuitively choose things that
you know are going
to work for them.
The other way is the
feedback sheet.
So every time the students
tell you, oh, this really
helps me or this really didn't
help me at all, you now have
one more piece of feedback about
what works for them and
what doesn't work for them.
So then, you can actually choose
intuition examples.
How do you invent them
from scratch?
Well, there are some
general principles.
One is use pictures
whenever you can.
Generally, that speaks to
people's intuition, just
because people have much more
hardware for pictures than
they have for equations.
So I try to put myself in the
position of the student, and I
say, well, for example, here.
I say, yeah, all these equations
may well be true,
but I want a way that makes
me see it instantly.
And that just forces me to start
looking for pictures.
And that tunes me, actually,
towards what students need.
So you can do the same.
I think that was most
of the questions.
The other questions were
similar to that.
And I'll answer any that were
new that I haven't answered--
but I think most of them
I have answered--
at the beginning of
the next lecture.
So any questions that were
generated by the questions?
Yes, question.
AUDIENCE: So your story about
the physics retension issue
made me question the idea of the
survey courses or topics
in class, where it's like,
I don't really
need to learn this.
I just want you to-- been
exposed to it so that they
remember enough to know
to go back to it
if you need it someday.
That research, that that has
any prayer of working.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the comment was what I'd
said about even a year of
intense freshman physics--
maybe it was a semester.
I forget if it was
just mechanics.
But it was either one semester
or a whole year freshman
physics did no good towards long
term understanding and
change of understanding
of freshman physics.
Well, what does that say about
these big survey classes,
where you're not expected
to understand?
So in freshman physics,
at least they have the
expectation that you're
supposed to understand
everything.
Now, what about the courses
where they start with the
expectation that you're
not going to
understand most of it?
That one is going to be
totally hopeless.
Then I think that is
basically true.
And maybe you could justify
back in the day--
let's say, 400 years ago, even
when books were around but
there was no web.
People need to know what
books are out there.
So this is a traditional thing
in Cambridge, for example.
They just give people big
huge reading lists.
So then you go back.
Later, you're like OK, these are
the key books in the area.
So you know one place to
go for a reading list.
That's kind of obsolete
now with the web.
If you want to find
out something--
for example, suppose there
was an equation
I didn't know about.
Let's say the Black-Scholes
equation.
Would I say I wonder if I
took any classes about
Black-Sholes--
maybe, let me go flip through
all my course notes?
No.
You just type it into some web
search and see what shows up.
And that is much more likely to
be more relevant than some
notes that you might have
had or not had.
So yeah, I think the
survey courses
are completely pointless.
Now, that doesn't mean
that introduction
to a field is pointless.
But it means that the way to do
the introduction has to be
very different.
You can't just scatter a bunch
of topics at people.
What you have to do is figure
out-- and we're going to talk
about this when we talk
about course design.
You have to figure out what are
the core reasoning ideas
special that that field has
to offer to the world?
For example, history--
what's special about history?
Well, historians have a sense
of how to evaluate the
validity and reliability
of evidence and
contradictory evidence.
That's something you don't
get in many other fields.
For example, it's in between
a science and a
pure literature field.
In just straight literature,
reading novels, there's
historical evidence and things,
but generally, you're
reading in a different way.
In math, it's hard to know where
contradictory evidence
comes in, although there are
ways of teaching math which I
like which do that.
But generally, history has
something new to offer, which
is it's a messy world.
You have noisy evidence.
What do you do?
Well, that's something that an
intro survey course could
actually teach.
And that, somebody could
transfer, even if they don't
remember when did the Magyars
invade Europe and all the
random stuff that would
be in a survey course.
So those would be grist for the
mill hung off big ideas.
So I'm going to talk about
that when we talk
about course design.
But yeah, you're right.
That course design is completely
hopeless the
general big survey.
Other questions?
Yes.
Could you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Meg.
PROFESSOR: Meg.
And what was your name?
AUDIENCE: Amy.
PROFESSOR: Amy.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was [INAUDIBLE].
I was just thinking about how
for me, even if I understand
something really well at the
time, and I know that I'll use
it again, it takes me--
having a test in front of me
will not actually reflect
whether or not I'm going to
understand it, given the short
period of time to
remind myself.
And so I'm wondering, if testing
people out of the blue
a year later is actually
capturing whether the people
who take this and perform
faster [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
That's a good question.
So maybe it was a slightly
unfair test, because they were
just tested out of the blue.
AUDIENCE: If they had been using
it all along-- if, in
that period of time, they had
taken courses that built on
that material--
then, they would be reinforcing
it all the
time if they can.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So if they had taken courses
that used freshman physics
throughout, maybe they would
have remembered the freshman
physics better.
And I'm sure that that's true.
So I can tell you one story
from my graduate time.
So I did a Ph.D. In physics.
And I had to do the
qualifying exam.
And to do the qualifying exam,
you have to study a whole
bunch of undergraduate physics
and then take the exams on it.
And then you take a bunch of
courses in various fields.
Now, the only thing, basically,
I remember from all
the electromagnetism is one
thing, which is I understand
pretty well the index
of refraction.
And why is that?
That's because I was
really pissed off--
sorry for the camera.
I was really annoyed about
the following thing.
So this actually goes back to
what I was talking about about
contradictions, which is that
you're always told in
relativity that speed of light
equals C. And that's the great
postulate of relativity--
that the speed of light does
not change, dammit.
And that's what Einstein said.
And there's all these thought
experiments with trains and
lightning bolts and people
throwing rocks from the train
at different speeds.
And it's C. It's C. It's C.
And then, somewhere later in
an electromagnetism course,
they say, the speed of light in
a medium with an index of
refraction N is C over N, where
N is typically around 1,
maybe a little bigger
like 1.001 for air
maybe, 1.33 for class.
And how do those fit together?
So that really annoyed me.
And I wanted to get to the root
of it and say, well, how
could it be that you could have
a speed of light that's
always C, yet it looks like
the speed is some
lower number, V?
So I worked out a whole bunch
of stuff about how electrons
scatter radiation and all the
scattered radiation adds up
and makes it seem like it's
slowing down the light.
And because of that, I actually
understand this.
And also because of that, which
may be not so good,
every time there's an
electromagnetism problem I
have to do, I always try to fit
into a scattering problem.
And if I can't do that, then
I just can't do it at all.
And that's despite taking two
years of electromagnetism--
two years as an undergrad and
one year as reviewing as a
grad student.
So the point I'm trying to
make by that is that most
stuff disappears.
And the way to really make stuff
stay is you really have
to struggle with something.
And that's the most efficient
way to make something stay.
And that's not what happens in
your traditional class, and
even less in a survey class.
AUDIENCE: I'm just
also asking--
it's almost impossible sometimes
when you see
material for the first time--
you might have to see it three
or four times before anything
comes, you're really going to
understand it.
And if the class is set up so
that you will only see it one
time because that's all the time
you have, then you have
to take more classes on it.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So maybe you need to see
something a few times to
really understand it.
So if a class doesn't give you
that chance and then you have
to take Thermo Two and
then Thermo Three.
AUDIENCE: Hopefully the class
gives you a chance.
Say that it's building
on this.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So you should try to build
that into the class.
So there's a name for that,
which is called the spiral
curriculum.
And there's a lot of
sense to that.
So I'll just put a quick--
so you show the idea
in its crude form.
And then you spiral back to it
in a more sophisticated way.
But you'd like to do that soon,
before the connection is
gone, before this is actually
wafted away.
You want to spiral back to it.
And so you'd like your
class to do that.
So what that shows is that you
should start with the big
ideas and then you should refine
them, because if you
start with all the little
details here, you'll just
flood the chunking system.
And actually, there will be no
memory of it here and then you
have to start over from
scratch here.
You had a question.
Could you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Roderigo.
PROFESSOR: Rodrigo, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Regarding the reading
memos, do you think
good to also ask the students
questions about the readings?
The reason why I am asking is
because I know of a class
that's actually implemented that
PDF annotation system.
And a lot of the comments
that they get are too
trivial, so to speak.
They don't ask those
type of questions.
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So the comment is
that a class that actually
implemented the online
annotation system, they found
that the comments are too micro
level and not broad
enough about what's really
confusing or interesting.
And so I haven't tried the
online system myself yet.
What I do know is that on the
paper, if you do it on paper,
you get really insightful,
detailed comments.
Now, I don't know what variables
are different.
One might be that the online
system just encourages--
because everyone does things
quick online-- it encourages
quick clicking.
So it may be that it encourages
less depth of
thinking, whereas writing it
on paper, I actually find I
get a mix of a whole bunch of
not trivial comments, but
small comments like, some typos,
that equation isn't
quite right.
But then I get things like, I
don't see the picture here or
I don't understand why
you did this now.
And that, to my mind, is it
useful comment-- or a question
like that can't be right because
of the following
counter argument.
So on paper, I get a lot
of interesting things.
So it may be that online
isn't as good.
And that's one reason I want
to try it and see.
So it may be that they need to
go back to paper despite it
being harder.
Another is also what
is the material?
If the material is really
boring, you're going to get
really micro comments.
So it helps to actually have
written interesting material
or give people interesting stuff
to read that people are
likely to think about
and make comments.
Question.
Can you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Brian.
PROFESSOR: Brian.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I notice when you talk
about equations, you like
to give them the name that
they're most commonly
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you find that students get
more understanding of concepts
like this when they're given a
name based on discovery versus
terminology based on use
of the equation?
I think, from my mind, if
you want to describe the
relationship between stress and
strain in material, do you
want to call it Hooke's law?
Or do you just want to call it
the constitutive equation for
solid material?
PROFESSOR: Right.
OK.
So the question is what about
naming equations?
Should you name them by who made
them or by how they're
used or what they are?
So another example of that is,
for example, the fluid
mechanics equation.
Should you call them
Navier-Stokes or should you
call them fundamental
fluid equations?
And there's a tension there.
First of all, I'll say that you
do want to give a name.
The big win is giving the thing
a name, because that
makes a unit of thought
for the students.
So that's the first order bit,
the first order term.
The second order term is
how should you name it?
And there, there's something
which is that you want a name
that's common.
So if, for example, people look
it up elsewhere, they're
likely to find more
stuff about it.
On the other hand, you want
a name that's intuitively
meaningful.
So there's a tension.
There's not often a right
answer to that.
And you can go either way.
So for example, I wouldn't
probably use constitutive
equation for the solid, because
I have to think, what
the hell does constitutive
mean?
So myself, it doesn't
mean anything to me.
There's another word.
I'm trying to remember
what it is.
Epistemology--
people just use it like it's
just a plain, obvious word.
But every time I hear it,
I have think, what the
hell does that mean?
And then I put the translation
into the
sentence they're saying.
And then I can sort of parse
what they're saying.
So constitutive equation, to my
mind, that's a word that is
meaningful to the experts and
not so much to the students.
So I would maybe call it the
ideal spring equation, because
it is the ideal spring
equation.
It's just the proportionality
is slightly general because
you have tensors.
But otherwise, it is the
ideal spring equation.
So it connects to something.
And you can say, OK,
who discovered?
Hooke.
So we often called
it Hooke's Law.
So then they have both And
there's no harm in doing that.
Question.
AUDIENCE: Because you mentioned
a little bit before
[INAUDIBLE].
If you're trying to teach
something many times, then
maybe it's better to tell
the end, and then--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the spiral.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And I was just thinking because
of the whole work--
so there are these really topics
like the ideal gas law.
And is it OK if I were to lie
or say to students just for
the sake of simplicity, for
example, do you want to say
whether you can actually use
that equation in some cases or
is it not logical always,
and then you go--
PROFESSOR: Could you
tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Cecilia.
PROFESSOR: Cecilia.
Yeah, thank you.
That's an excellent
question as well.
So the question is, how much
should you lie, if at all?
For example, if I'm recommending
teaching the big
ideas in the overall approach
first, that's almost
necessarily going to involve
some amount of lying, because
the truth is complex and
messy, the full truth.
And basically, you
do want to lie.
Some people hate it.
But there's actually a
really good book that
follows this principle.
And even if you're not
interested in the typesetting
system, you can see how it's
played out in this book.
It's called The Tech Book.
So that's the manual for the
tech typesetting system, which
I use and many people in
math and physics use.
Now, the reason it's interesting
is that Knuth
actually tells you in
the preface, I'm
going to lie to you.
So what he does is he has three
levels of statements.
There's statements that
aren't marked with a--
so there's that sign.
On the road, it means slippery,
icy, something like
your car might fish tail
basically, danger.
So there are statements without
one of these, which
may have some lies in it, not
the full truth so that you
just get the idea--
what are the fundamental
concepts that tech uses.
When he starts to get into some
gory details, but not
super gory.
He puts one of those bends.
And when he has a super
gory details, there's
two of those bends.
And then he says, look, don't
read any of these things
unless you've been working with
tech for a year and are
pretty competent with it.
Don't worry about that.
You'll be able to do what you
need to do just by reading
this and maybe the single
bend sections.
So that's an example where
the lying was put
to really good use.
And yeah, you should lie.
In fact, you have to lie.
There's no way to avoid it.
And in fact, everything
is a lie.
It has to be, because to
understand the universe, our
brains are a constituent
of the universe.
So there's no way to understand
the full universe,
because that would involved
packing more than our brain
capacity into our brain.
So just there is a pigeon hole
principle proof that you have
to lie to understand
the universe.
So you have to say some stuff
that isn't quite true.
And where the art is is in
choosing what is a useful lie.
So what you want to
do is develop the
art of skillful lying.
And that's a mark of a really,
really good teacher--
skillful lying.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How do we know that
you're not lying to us now?
PROFESSOR: I probably am.
The question is how do
you know that I'm not
lying to you now?
And I probably am, the reason
being that I've now practiced
lying so much, I don't even
know when I'm lying
and when I'm not.
So no, I'll give
you an example.
I am definitely lying
to some extent.
For example, there probably are
situations where you don't
want to any lies at all-- for
example, teaching people how
to manipulate the machines in
the intensive care unit.
Maybe the first thing you need--
if you have a half an
hour to teach them, you'd better
teach them, memorize
these damn things and
don't mess it up
or you'll kill somebody.
Maybe there are situations where
lying is less important
and lying is more important.
And I haven't talked
about those.
So right away, I have lied to
you, just because that.
And I've skipped details because
I wanted to get the
big idea across.
So lying actually comes very
naturally to me because I
think the most important thing
is the big details.
So just by saying big details
first, you're
automatically lying.
And I'm recommending it
highly to you, too.
Rodrigo.
AUDIENCE: I have a comment
on the lying.
As a student, I have students,
a lot of friends, who told me
that they don't like it
when teachers lie.
But what I think the
differentiating factor is
whether they tell you that
they're actually lying.
And if they do, then
it's totally fine.
And if they don't, and a couple
months from there, they
just told you that everything
was not really true, the
students might get upset.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So the comment is that students
often don't like when
they find out that they've
been lied to.
But it's OK if you tell them
that you're lying to them.
And there's a general principle
there which you can
use in all your teaching, which
is that whenever you do
anything slightly
nontraditional--
whenever you do anything like
that-- it's really important
to tell the students what you're
doing and why, because
they will go with you.
They'll go along with you
if you explain to them
the motive for it.
So you tell them, look, this is
a really complex subject.
There is no way to understand
the whole subject
at its first glance.
You need to develop high
level structures first.
And then you can put in the
details underneath that.
So I'm going to tell
you just the high
level structures first.
And there will be some untruths
in that, but I'm not
going to tell you things that
are completely false that you
have unlearn.
I'm going to tell you things
that you have to refine your
understanding of or that
aren't the whole truth.
So together with the idea of
lying, you want to minimize
stuff that you tell them that
they have to unlearn and make
it so that you're telling
them stuff that
they can keep using.
It's just not the full story.
OK.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to give you just a quick
example of another equation and
how you could teach it.
Then we'll take a short break
and then we'll do
misconceptions.
OK.
So the other equation that I
want to explain is this one.
So I did a biology example
before, so I chose a physics
equation this time, which
is the wave equation.
OK.
Now, also to vary it, with the
biology example, I introduced
it with a bit of history.
With the wave equation, I'm
going to actually introduce it
with a different approach, which
is not to talk about the
history but actually to get
the students to try to
construct the equation.
OK.
So the question is what the
hell is the wave equation?
Well, the wave equation
describes--
so here's some string.
And here's your coordinate x.
And you want to know how does
the height of this piece here,
the height being f of x as a
function of time as well,
change with position
and with time?
So you want to figure out an
equation for that behavior of
that string, that stretch
between two points.
For example, this might be a
guitar string, and these are
the two ends of the
guitar string.
And it' under tension.
And you want to know,
how does it move?
OK.
So we're going to construct
the equation.
So let's say this is a
differential equations class
for people in physics who are
learning mathematical methods.
And they want to learn
how to construct
differential equations.
So maybe they're engineers,
physicists.
And they're, say, juniors.
So they have some mathematical
sophistication and some
knowledge of forces in physics
and some knowledge of
differential equations.
So I'm going to write down the
rough form of the equation,
and we're going to try to figure
out all the pieces and
fill in the missing pieces.
So I'm going to give the general
form of the thing.
So there's some derivative of
f with respect to time--
one or two derivatives,
we're not sure--
is equal to something here.
And then there's some constant
here or maybe here.
So there's a whole bunch of
question marks to fill in.
And what we're going to do is
reason about what they are.
OK.
So the first question is
to figure out this guy.
How many time derivatives
do we need?
So what this equation describes
is the motion of
this point.
Now, why does the point move?
Well, you could ask the class,
and eventually, they'll come
up with, well, there's some
forces on it, because the
string's under tension, so
there's forces on the point.
So here's our point.
And here's, say, the string
going through it.
This is a blow up now
of this region.
OK.
So now, what are the
forces on this guy?
Well, there's a force from that
piece of the string and a
force from that piece
of the string.
OK.
Because there's force, what's
going to happen to the thing?
Is it going to have a velocity
or an acceleration?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: Acceleration.
PROFESSOR: Acceleration.
OK.
How many derivatives does
acceleration have?
Two.
OK.
So we're going to put two
derivatives here.
So you need two derivatives.
So this, and now, we're going
to say this is some kind of
acceleration.
And maybe there's masses in
there and stuff, which would
all be slurped into
these constants.
So we have an acceleration.
And now, we have to decide what
generates acceleration.
This side is generating
acceleration or the force.
So we want to decide, for
example, one or two
derivatives.
Generally, most equations
either have one
derivative or two.
Some really nasty
ones have four.
But generally, it's
one or two.
So we'll just choose.
Is this one or two?
OK.
And then the last thing we're
going to do is to figure out
the constant.
OK.
So now, one or two derivatives--
one way to
decide that is to make something
that has just one
derivative in it.
So if here is my string and
here is the point--
so f has a non-zero--
so it has a non-zero df/dx.
But the second derivative
is 0, because
it's a straight line.
OK.
So we know the second
derivative is 0.
Let's see what we can figure
out what the force or the
acceleration should be.
OK.
Well, here is a point.
There's going to be a force on
it from that end and that end.
And what's the net result
of these two forces?
0.
So when the second derivative
is 0, in this case at least,
we would like the force to be 0,
which means that force has
to be connected to the second
derivative of position.
So we got that.
Now, the next problem is to
work out what goes here.
The first thing is
what's the sine.
Should it be plus or minus?
OK.
So I'm going to ask you that.
So find a reason whether it
should be plus or minus here
and a reason.
So find a neighbor or two,
and we'll take a vote--
plus or minus, intuitive
reason for it.
I can't use this example
to decide.
Let's vote.
Everyone have their
votes ready?
Who votes for plus?
So about--
who votes for minus?
OK.
That's great.
So we have a diversity
of opinion.
So right away, what that shows
you is that it's worth
actually discussing that point
in class, because if you just
tell people, they'll write down
something you tell them,
but they won't have actually
internalized it.
It'll just be something that
maybe contradicted what they
said, thought, or not.
And then they have to remember,
was it what I
thought or was what
I not thought?
Or was it what I not thought
or what I thought?
So they don't actually
understand why.
So it's actually worth going
through the discussion.
So what example could
you use to decide?
Who haven't I heard from?
Yeah.
Could you tell me your name?
AUDIENCE: Mike.
PROFESSOR: Mike.
AUDIENCE: Well, if you're at
the top of the arc, and you
don't it's going to want
to be pulled down.
It's coming down.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So let's use an arc like this.
We can't use this one,
because it's 0, and 0
doesn't have a sign.
So it doesn't help us.
So the next most complicated
thing is this--
so an arc like that.
Here's my point.
So the force is downwards, or
the acceleration is downwards.
So we should have negative
acceleration.
And what's the second derivative
with respect to
position here?
That's also downwards, because
the arc is like that.
So the derivative has
the same direction--
the space derivative and
the acceleration.
So it should be plus.
So we got the sign right.
And to emphasize the importance
of getting the
signs, there's an interesting
comment from Feynman back in
the '60s at some conference
about quantum electrodynamics.
He was commenting about how
crazy the whole process that
he invented for solving quantum
electrodynamics is.
And his reason that
is so crazy--
he said, well, we do the first
order term, and then we
calculate the second order term
and add it to the first
order term.
But it's very worrying that when
we calculate the second
order term after the first
order term, we don't know
whether the second order term
is positive or negative.
We just have to calculate it and
see what it's going to be.
But we can't predict ahead
of time whether
it's positive or negative.
And what that speaks to is the
importance that physicists
attach to knowing the
sign of an effect.
Is a plus or is it a minus?
And so that's fundamentally
important.
You want to make sure
you get that right.
Now, why did I do the sign of
the effect after this, after
the order of the derivatives?
Because the most important
thing is what
do the terms mean.
So this is a curvature.
This is an acceleration.
So here, let me write that--
curvature.
Until you know what the terms
mean, there's no hope of
figuring out what the sign
that connects them is.
But the sign is the very
next thing you do.
And it's really important.
It's a plus.
And now, we need to put in one
more thing, because the
dimensions are totally bogus.
This is a position divided
by a times squared.
by a length squared.
So we need to actually multiply
by something to make
the units come out correct.
So we need something that puts
a time squared here and a
position squared over here.
So then the units will work
out-- or a position squared
over time squared, which
is C squared, which
is some speed squared.
So speed squared is position
squared over time squared.
And that makes all the
units work out.
So there you go.
There you have the
wave equation.
So now, if you're going to
actually formally derive it,
that's all fine.
But I would do this first so
that people know where every
single term in the equation
comes from.
And now, I've been
a bit sloppy.
These are really partial
derivatives.
But that's, again, an
example of lying.
I wouldn't worry about whether
it's a partial or total
derivative at the beginning,
because that's not the
fundamental idea.
The fundamental idea is that
it's curvature on this side
connecting to acceleration
on this side, and they're
connected by a positive sign
and by something that has
dimensions of speed squared,
which turns out to be the
speed at which the wave moves.
So that's a way to introduce
yet another equation, not
related to the history, but
actually connecting to the
intuitive approach.
Any questions about that?